locates GLAAD's listen up there's more
than one way to end a game of sports
ball says the walk-off home run the
sudden-death gold the buzzer beater but
within the adrenaline adult psyche of
the American sports fan can any of them
produce a heart attack like a successful
el Mary pass don't answer that it's
rhetorical choir Hail Marys special
because their unicorn since 1975 there's
only been 28 of them in professional
football why because they're almost
impossible to get right to complete a
Hail Mary the path needs to be long like
thrown from midfield long with little or
no time remaining on the clock and you
need to be losing and the past listening
to a touchdown the results that at least
deprived a preferable a win that is a
Hail Mary he most quarterbacks are
likelier to marry a supermodel to throw
a successful he'll marry in their career
exhibit a Tom Brady the heart of display
which practically requires an act of God
to come to Beth see what I did there
easy with a prayer tell Mary full of
grace the Lord is with thee so it's
December 28 1975 50 yards from the end
zone but needing a touchdown to win
Cowboys quarterback and devout Catholic
Roger Staubach whispers a Hail Mary to
himself hello Mary full of grace the
Lord is with thee and launches a
desperation pass to receive a Drew
Pearson the Cowboys win and the Hail
Mary is christened forevermore any
questions good now go win me some ball
games
I